Alright. So I'd like to talk just really briefly about building a test
suite for a piece of software. So test suite is just a collection
of tests. And it's often the case that the test suite can be
run automatically. It's also often the case
that test suite gets run periodically. So
for example, perhaps nightly, on every
commit. Although in many cases that's infeasible,
since, if commits are frequent and the test case is slow. The goal of
a test suite is to show that some software under test has some
desired properties, namely passing all of the
tests. Although it's very common for real
software to almost always be in a state of partial failure. But what
we hope is that most of the time, most of these failures are
not particularly severe ones. So the
question is, if you're maintaining a software
project, what goes into the test suite? And to a large extent, this is
a matter of taste and preference, but on the other hand there's some
pretty common features of nearly all test
suites. It's very common, first of all,
to have a lot of unit tests or at least feature-specific tests that
are small tests that exercise very specialized
behaviors. So, for example, if we're developing
some sort of a web browser, we might have tested effect that different
HTML elements render correctly and that sort of thing. It's also very common
for a test suite to contain large realistic inputs. So, for example, if
we're testing some sort of a microprocessor, maybe we'd boot up Linux and
run it for a couple of hours, and the purpose of these kind
of inputs is to provide realistic stresses on the system. And to exercise
a lot of features and combination. And make sure that things are up
to scuff. It's nearly, always a good idea to include regression tests in
a test suite. Now, regression tests is
basically any input that's cause any version
in the software in the test, to fail at any time. And, there are several
reasons regression tests exist. The main one of which, is we want to make sure
that the software in your test doesn't regress. That is to say that it doesn't
go back into a state in which it fails on a bug that we
already fixed. There are a number of
reasons why that could happen. First of all,
regression tests are useful because whatever the
defect was in the software that caused the
bug in the first place, we might not have gotten rid of all the instances
of that defect in a source code. So, for example, a buggy piece of
code might have been cut and pasted to several other places, and those other
locations might not be causing our system
to fail currently, but some other change
might enable the buggy code to fire, and make the bug happen again. Another
reason is it is pretty easy through, for example, mess ups with the revision
control system. To accidently go back to an old version of a file, before
we fix the bug; if that happens we want to catch it as soon
as possible, because, because some regression test
trips. Third reasons is that defect in software
come from errors in people's thinking, it's
pretty often the case, that the person
who introduce the defect into the software;
didn't actually correct the error that they
had in their thinking. Rather maybe somebody else fix the defect. And the person
retains their mistaken assumption about some sort
of an API or something. And due
to this latent error in somebody's head, they can go ahead and start adding
similar defects to the system later on. And if we have good regression tests,
we stand more of a chance of catching those kind of things. And something
that usually doesn't go into a test suite is a random tester. And for whatever
reason I'm not totally sure that I
understand all the reasons even. Random testing
is often treated as a separate activity. This is related to the fact that random
tests often are non deterministic unless we're
being careful to preserve the same seed. They
don't have a clear correctness criterion. And
perhaps more importantly, random tests always have a
possibility of showing us something new. That
is to say, they have the possibility of
introducing a test case that we haven't
seen before. In fact, that's what we hope
will happen. And the reason that might
be undesirable, is the test suite is supposed
to be predictable. It's supposed to consist of things that we know to test for.
Now, if all of a sudden, the test
starts containing new and different tests, then that's
not necessarily good. So, for whatever combination of
these reasons, random testing is often a separate activity.